عوده مطار دمش خروج المطار عن الخدمه
تواصل قوات النظام قصف بلدات وقرى في ريفي
ادلب
وحلبي على كليه
عسكريه ظنا قانون عفو عن كل من تورط
بالاحداث خلال السنوات الماضيه عام من
الاحداث الساخنه في سوريا قتل فيه اكثر من
1000 شخص معظمهم بنيران الاسد وحلفائه
بحسب الشبكه السوريه لحقوق الانسان وغابت
عنه الحلول السياسيه ووعود اعاده الاعمار
وخروج المعتقلين وكان عنوانه كارثه طبيعيه
وهجره مستمره وتدهور اقتصادي بدا عام
2023 بتلميح تركي للتطبيع مع دمشق رغم
لقاء جمع وزيري خارجيه البلدين في موسكو
في مايو ايار لم تنجح جهود التقارب وظهرت
مبكرا هذا العام مؤشرات ازمه انسانيه بعد
تهديد موسكو بتعليق قرار اممي يصدر دوريا
في مجلس الامن يسمح بدخول مساعدات لمناطق
المعارضه السوريه في الشمال لكن مجلس
الامن نجح في تمديد اليه ادخال المساعدات
الامميه دون اذن من دمشق لمده سته اشهر قد
ت منظمه حضر الاسلحه الكيميائيه لاول مره
اتهاما صريحا الى الاسد بارتكاب هجوم
كيميائي ادى الى مقتل 43 شخصا في مدينه
دوما بريف دمشق عام
[موسيقى]
2018 وفي ليله السادس من فبراير شباط شهدت
سوريا واحدا من في الزلازل في التاريخ
الحديث ضرب مدينه كهرمان مرعش التركيه
وامتدت اثاره الى خمس محافظات سوريه بلغ
عدد القتلى في سوريا 6000 معظمهم في مناطق
المعارضه واتهم الدفاع المدني الامم
المتحده ودمشق بالتواطؤ لتاخير وصول
المساعدات المنقذه للحياه ما تسبب بفقدان
كثير من الارواح لماذا حدث هذا التقصير في
مناطق شمال غرب سوريا ماذا المساعدات وصلت
الى مناطق النظام السوري ولم تصل الى
مناطق شمال غرب سوريا قدرت الخسائر
الاقتصاديه التي احدثها الزلزال باكثر من
خمسه مليارات دولار بحسب البنك الدولي
عززت هذه الكارثه جهود التقارب العربي مع
دمشق وكانت سببا لتدفق المساعدات نحو دمشق
رغم ان نسبه 90% من الاضرار كانت في ادلب
وخرج بشار الاسد في زيارتين خارجيتين الى
موسكو وابو ظبي بعد الزلزال ثم تسلم مقعد
سوريا في اجتماع الجامعه العربيه في جده
وذلك لاول مره منذ اندلاع الثوره السوريه
عام
2011 وربما ينتقل الانسان من حضن لاخر
لسبب ما لكنه لا يغير انتماءه لم تحدث
انفراجه في القضايا التي نوقشت قبل
التقارب مع الاسد وعلى راسها ملف تهريب
المخدرات من سوريا وعوده
اذ شهدت الحدود السوريه الاردنيه بعد
التقارب عشرات محاولات التهريب وهو ما دفع
الاردن الى استخدام سلاح الجو عده مرات
لاحباط تلك
العمليات الاقتصاد السوري واصل تدهوره على
عكس التوقعات وبقيت سوريا في صداره الدول
المصدره للمهاجرين الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
وتراجعت الره السوريه بنسبه 100% خلال 11
شهرا وادى هذا الى تعاظم الاصوات الغاضبه
في اغسطس اب اندلعت احتجاجات عارمه في
محافظه السويداء جنوبا رفعت فيها لاول مره
شعارات الثوره السوريه ورايتها ثم امتدت
سريعا الى درعا وريف دير الزور
وادلب ولم تتسع دائره التقارب خارج الاطار
الاقليمي اذ اصدرت الولايات المتحده قانون
الكبتاجون لتشديد العقوبات على دمشق وصدرت
لاول مره مذكره توقيف دوليه لبشار الاسد
بامر القضاء الفرنسي بتهمه التواطئ في
جرائم ضد الانسانيه في هجمات كيميائيه في
عام
2013 وشهد الشرق السوري مواجهات داميه
طرفاها مقاتلون من العشائر العربيه في دير
الزور في مواجهه ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه المدعومه من التحالف الدولي
استمرت المعارك اسابيع في بلدات ذبانه
والميادين ووصلت الى اطراف حقل العمر قبل
ان تنحسر بعد مفاوضات برعايه التحالف
الدولي